This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. If you make at least $30,000 a year, congratulations. Your income is 10 times the global median, and in the top 5% of incomes worldwide. If you are older than 35, congratulations. For much of human history, many people died before they were 30. If you have a job and stable income, live in a democratic country and have a college degree, you are in a rarefied group in
This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. If you make at least $30,000 a year, congratulations. Your income is 10 times the global median, and in the top 5% of incomes worldwide. If you are older than 35, congratulations. For much of human history, many people died before they were 30. If you have a job and stable income, live in a democratic country and have a college degree, you are in a rarefied group in|||这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹坦姆。如果你一年的收入至少有3万美元，恭喜你。你的收入是全球中位数的10倍，位列全球收入前5%。如果你年龄超过35岁，恭喜你。在人类历史的大部分时间里，许多人在30岁之前就去世了。如果你有一份工作和稳定的收入，生活在一个民主国家并拥有大学学位，你在人类历史上属于凤毛麟角的群体。
the history of humankind. If you enjoy good health, good friends, nice vacations, you're really ought to get down on your knees yet? Why is it even when our lives are objectively better than the lives of most people who have lived, we are all prone to seeing the clouds, not the silver lining? This is true not just when it comes to global and historical statistics, but in our daily lives. We notice small delays at the airport, but ignore the miracle that we can literally fly across the world.
the history of humankind. If you enjoy good health, good friends, nice vacations, you're really ought to get down on your knees yet? Why is it even when our lives are objectively better than the lives of most people who have lived, we are all prone to seeing the clouds, not the silver lining? This is true not just when it comes to global and historical statistics, but in our daily lives. We notice small delays at the airport, but ignore the miracle that we can literally fly across the world.|||如果你享有健康的身体、好朋友、美好的假期，你真的该跪下感谢上天了吗？为什么即使我们的生活客观上比绝大多数生活过的人都要好，我们却总是倾向于看到乌云，而不是乌云背后的银边？不仅在全球和历史数据面前如此，在我们的日常生活中也是如此。我们注意到机场的小延误，却忽视了我们能够真正飞越世界的奇迹。
We take our health for granted, and only notice the gifts of our limbs and our senses when they are taken away from us. We zero in on annoyances in personal relationships, and rarely pause to acknowledge what is wonderful about our friends, families and co-workers. Our ungratitude for our good fortune is so automatic and ubiquitous that it seems obvious they must be an underlying psychology to it. That's the topic of today's show. The enemies of gratitude and how to fight them. This week on Hidden Brain. If you try to measure the size of an ant using a telescope, you won't get very far. If you try to measure the size of an ant using a telescope, you won't get very far.
We take our health for granted, and only notice the gifts of our limbs and our senses when they are taken away from us. We zero in on annoyances in personal relationships, and rarely pause to acknowledge what is wonderful about our friends, families and co-workers. Our ungratitude for our good fortune is so automatic and ubiquitous that it seems obvious they must be an underlying psychology to it. That's the topic of today's show. The enemies of gratitude and how to fight them. This week on Hidden Brain. If you try to measure the size of an ant using a telescope, you won't get very far. If you try to measure the size of an ant using a telescope, you won't get very far.|||我们把健康视为理所当然，只有当四肢和感官被剥夺时，才注意到它们是多么宝贵的礼物。我们专注于人际关系中的烦恼，却很少停下来去欣赏朋友、家人和同事的美好之处。我们对好运的不知感恩是如此的机械和普遍，以至于显而易见，其中必然存在着某种潜在的心理机制。这就是今天节目的主题。感恩的敌人以及如何对抗它们。本周的《隐藏的大脑》。如果你试图用望远镜来测量一只蚂蚁的大小，你不会有什么进展。如果你试图用望远镜来测量一只蚂蚁的大小，你不会有什么进展。
If you try to gauge the distance between stars using a microscope, you'll be hopelessly lost. What's true in the physical world is also true inside our own minds. The tools we use to evaluate our lives, shape what we see, and whether we see. At Cornell University, psychologists Thomas Gillovich studies how we think about our successes and failures and why we often get important things wrong. Tom Gillovich, welcome to Hidden Brain. It's a pleasure to be on your show, Shankar.
If you try to gauge the distance between stars using a microscope, you'll be hopelessly lost. What's true in the physical world is also true inside our own minds. The tools we use to evaluate our lives, shape what we see, and whether we see. At Cornell University, psychologists Thomas Gillovich studies how we think about our successes and failures and why we often get important things wrong. Tom Gillovich, welcome to Hidden Brain. It's a pleasure to be on your show, Shankar.|||如果你试图用显微镜来衡量恒星之间的距离，你将彻底迷失。物理世界中如此，我们内心的世界也是如此。我们用来评估生活的工具，塑造了我们看到的东西，以及我们是否能看到。在康奈尔大学，心理学家托马斯·吉洛维奇研究我们如何看待成功与失败，以及为什么我们经常在重要的事情上犯错。汤姆·吉洛维奇，欢迎来到《隐藏的大脑》。很高兴能上你的节目，尚卡尔。
I want to take you all the way back to high school, Tom, between your junior and senior years of high school. I understand a friend of yours who was on the football team invited you over to take a look at a cool new gizmo he had acquired. Yes, the gizmo up to that point didn't seem cool to me. I didn't really have any interest in writing a motorcycle and always seemed dangerous to me. But my friend was much cooler than I, and when he rode it,
I want to take you all the way back to high school, Tom, between your junior and senior years of high school. I understand a friend of yours who was on the football team invited you over to take a look at a cool new gizmo he had acquired. Yes, the gizmo up to that point didn't seem cool to me. I didn't really have any interest in writing a motorcycle and always seemed dangerous to me. But my friend was much cooler than I, and when he rode it,|||汤姆，我想带你回到高中时代，也就是你高三的那年。据我所知，你的一位橄榄球队朋友邀请你去看看他买的一个很酷的新玩意儿。是的，那个小玩意儿在那之前对我来说并不怎么酷。我对骑摩托车其实没什么兴趣，而且它总是让我觉得很危险。但我的朋友比我酷得多，当他骑着它时，
it seemed kind of cool, so I asked him if he could give me a lesson, show me how to do it. So we're in his front yard, and he's showing me the different brakes. This one breaks the rear wheel, this one breaks the front, here's the accelerator, et cetera, et cetera. And right before I'm about to start driving, he says, oh, this is really important. People often want to press with this break, which is going to break the front wheel without hitting the rear brake and people just go flying over the top.
it seemed kind of cool, so I asked him if he could give me a lesson, show me how to do it. So we're in his front yard, and he's showing me the different brakes. This one breaks the rear wheel, this one breaks the front, here's the accelerator, et cetera, et cetera. And right before I'm about to start driving, he says, oh, this is really important. People often want to press with this break, which is going to break the front wheel without hitting the rear brake and people just go flying over the top.|||它看起来确实挺酷的，所以我问他能不能教教我，示范一下怎么操作。于是我们来到他家的前院，他向我展示不同的刹车。这个刹车控制后轮，这个刹车控制前轮，这是油门，等等，等等。就在我准备开动之前，他说，哦，这非常重要。人们经常习惯性地踩这个刹车，这会只刹住前轮而不踩后轮，然后人就会直接从车上飞出去。
So whatever you do, if you get into trouble, make sure you're pressing the rear brake, which on this motorcycle was foot activated. Tom got on the motorcycle and zoomed off. He quickly accelerated. About 40 yards into his expedition, he realized he was going too fast. I'm heading out of his yard across the street. No problem, I say to myself, just find the rear brake and you'll be okay. And my foot is moving around trying to find it. I can't and I've just got this mantra. Don't hit the brake for the front wheel. And I go farther than I expect. I hit this fence in the yard across the street, plow right through it. The motorcycle hits a sturdy tree,
So whatever you do, if you get into trouble, make sure you're pressing the rear brake, which on this motorcycle was foot activated. Tom got on the motorcycle and zoomed off. He quickly accelerated. About 40 yards into his expedition, he realized he was going too fast. I'm heading out of his yard across the street. No problem, I say to myself, just find the rear brake and you'll be okay. And my foot is moving around trying to find it. I can't and I've just got this mantra. Don't hit the brake for the front wheel. And I go farther than I expect. I hit this fence in the yard across the street, plow right through it. The motorcycle hits a sturdy tree,|||所以无论如何，如果你遇到危险，一定要确保踩下后轮刹车——这辆摩托车的后轮刹车是用脚控制的。汤姆骑上摩托车飞驰而去。他迅速加速。大约前行了40码后，他意识到自己开得太快了。“我正冲出他家的院子，横穿马路。”没问题，我对自己说，只要找到后轮刹车，你就没事了。我的脚在慌乱地寻找它。我找不到，脑子里只有一个咒语：千万别按前轮刹车。结果我冲得比预想的还要远。我撞上了街对面院子的栅栏，直接撞了进去。摩托车撞到了一棵结实的树上，
I fly over the handlebars. If you've ever fallen off a bike, and time seems to slow down, and you say, okay, that definitely happened here. I knew something significant was about to happen and my head goes smack right into the tree. My god, and you know some kind of primal panic sets in. Tom was not wearing a hemat. His friend rushed over. I remember a loud sound and the kind of physical force that you feel when you're tackling
I fly over the handlebars. If you've ever fallen off a bike, and time seems to slow down, and you say, okay, that definitely happened here. I knew something significant was about to happen and my head goes smack right into the tree. My god, and you know some kind of primal panic sets in. Tom was not wearing a hemat. His friend rushed over. I remember a loud sound and the kind of physical force that you feel when you're tackling|||我从车把上飞了出去。如果你曾从自行车上摔下来过，就会觉得时间似乎变慢了，你会说，好吧，这种感觉我绝对经历过。我知道有大事要发生了，接着我的头“砰”的一声直接撞在了树上。天哪，你知道那种原始的恐慌涌上心头。汤姆当时没戴头盔。他的朋友冲了过来。我记得一声巨响，以及那种在橄榄球场上扑倒别人时感受到的物理冲击力。
someone in tackle football. Only it was associated with a greater sense of worry. I didn't initiate this. The motorcycle did and I, you don't tackle a tree, you tackle another person. So this had a greater sense of anticipatory dread. And did you actually get up after this impact? I mean, so you hit the tree, you presumably, how you've flown off, what happens? Do you land? What happens? Are you knocked out?
someone in tackle football. Only it was associated with a greater sense of worry. I didn't initiate this. The motorcycle did and I, you don't tackle a tree, you tackle another person. So this had a greater sense of anticipatory dread. And did you actually get up after this impact? I mean, so you hit the tree, you presumably, how you've flown off, what happens? Do you land? What happens? Are you knocked out?|||只不过这种冲击伴随着更强烈担忧。不是我主动发起的。是摩托车干的，而且——你不会去扑倒一棵树，你扑倒的是另一个人。所以这有一种更强烈的预知恐惧。你撞击后真的站起来了吗？我的意思是，你撞到了树，据推测，你是怎么飞出去的？后来怎么样了？你着陆了吗？发生了什么？你昏迷了吗？
No, I did get a concussion. I wasn't knocked out. The thing that I remember the most clearly is that afterwards, my friend and I peeled off a portion of my scalp from the tree. And I had heard about people having spinal cord injuries because of motorcycle accidents, and so it felt like an incredibly fortunate near miss. My God. And just afterwards had this incredible sense of good fortune. We read about people who have accidents like that and either die or lose important body functions. And that didn't happen to me and I had some other experiences
No, I did get a concussion. I wasn't knocked out. The thing that I remember the most clearly is that afterwards, my friend and I peeled off a portion of my scalp from the tree. And I had heard about people having spinal cord injuries because of motorcycle accidents, and so it felt like an incredibly fortunate near miss. My God. And just afterwards had this incredible sense of good fortune. We read about people who have accidents like that and either die or lose important body functions. And that didn't happen to me and I had some other experiences|||不，我确实得了脑震荡。我没有失去知觉。我记忆最清晰的是，事后我和朋友把贴在树上的一块头皮给撕了下来。我听说过有人因为摩托车事故导致脊髓损伤，所以我觉得这是一次极其幸运的死里逃生。天哪。事后我有一种难以置信的幸运感。我们读到过有人遭遇这种事故，要么丧命，要么失去重要的身体机能。而这并没有发生在我身上，我还有过其他一些经历——
like that, close calls where you say, wow, why am I so lucky? How did I survive this? this. Some years later, Tom experienced another moment of good fortune. The Vietnam War was raging, and Tom was eligible for the draft. And for me, that happened during a period of the war where enthusiasm for going in the United States had waned. So this is a real problem. I may go and be in harm's way, which would be fine for a good cause. At this point, it was widely thought of as not and especially good cause.
like that, close calls where you say, wow, why am I so lucky? How did I survive this? this. Some years later, Tom experienced another moment of good fortune. The Vietnam War was raging, and Tom was eligible for the draft. And for me, that happened during a period of the war where enthusiasm for going in the United States had waned. So this is a real problem. I may go and be in harm's way, which would be fine for a good cause. At this point, it was widely thought of as not and especially good cause.|||像那样的惊险时刻，你会说，哇，我怎么这么幸运？我是怎么活下来的？几年后，汤姆迎来了又一个幸运时刻。越战正酣，汤姆符合征兵条件。“对我来说，那正值美国参战热情消退的时期。所以这是一个真正的问题。我可能会去涉险，如果是为了一个崇高的事业倒也罢了。但在当时，这普遍被认为并不是一个特别崇高的事业。”
So this was a terrifying prospect. And what came of it? Did you end up getting drafted in going? I did not. That was the year that President Nixon's Vietnamization Program had really taken hold. More and more of the fighting was being done by the South Vietnamese. And therefore, there was less need to send young Americans over there. And I didn't have to serve something that I looked back on as a lucky break that people just a little bit older than I was did not enjoy. I want to fast forward to a third moment in your life when you felt very fortunate and this is your wife and you were trying to have a child. Tell me the story of what
So this was a terrifying prospect. And what came of it? Did you end up getting drafted in going? I did not. That was the year that President Nixon's Vietnamization Program had really taken hold. More and more of the fighting was being done by the South Vietnamese. And therefore, there was less need to send young Americans over there. And I didn't have to serve something that I looked back on as a lucky break that people just a little bit older than I was did not enjoy. I want to fast forward to a third moment in your life when you felt very fortunate and this is your wife and you were trying to have a child. Tell me the story of what|||所以这是一个可怕的前景。结果呢？你最终被征召入伍并去了吗？我没有。那一年，尼克松总统的“越南化”计划真正取得了成效。越来越多的战斗由南越军队承担。因此，派年轻的美国人去那里的需求减少了。我不用去服兵役，回想起来，这是一次幸运的机遇，而比我稍大一点的人并没有这种运气。我想快进到你生命中的第三个时刻，当时你觉得自己非常幸运，那就是你和你的妻子试图要一个孩子。跟我讲讲那天发生的故事。
happened. Yeah, like a lot of young couples, we thought it's time to have a family. And so we we did what people do to make sure that the most romantic moments are happening at the optimal times. But a couple years past and it wasn't happening. It became clear after a while that we might be good candidates for in vitro fertilization. So we went to the famous Howard and Georgina Jones Clinic in Norfolk, Virginia, and eggs are harvested from the potential mother, and they're in various conditions, and every time it was kind of like it didn't work and we tried this a number of times each time it didn't work it was just crushingly bad news
happened. Yeah, like a lot of young couples, we thought it's time to have a family. And so we we did what people do to make sure that the most romantic moments are happening at the optimal times. But a couple years past and it wasn't happening. It became clear after a while that we might be good candidates for in vitro fertilization. So we went to the famous Howard and Georgina Jones Clinic in Norfolk, Virginia, and eggs are harvested from the potential mother, and they're in various conditions, and every time it was kind of like it didn't work and we tried this a number of times each time it didn't work it was just crushingly bad news|||是的，就像许多年轻夫妇一样，我们觉得是时候组建一个家庭了。于是我们按照人们惯常的做法，确保最浪漫的时刻发生在最佳时机。但几年过去了，毫无动静。过了一段时间，很明显我们可能是试管婴儿的合适人选。于是我们去了弗吉尼亚州诺福克著名的霍华德和乔治娜·琼斯诊所，从准母亲体内取出卵子，它们处于不同的状态，但每一次都以失败告终。我们尝试了好几次，每一次失败都是令人心碎的坏消息。
some of the saddest moments of our lives and the process is really difficult right? It's not it's not a trivial process for the woman it's not a trivial process at all women have to take hormones so that it's not a trivial process. For the woman, it's not a trivial process at all. Women have to take hormones so that it's not just one egg that matures and can get harvested. And of course, it has to be surgically removed. So yes, it's a big deal. So these were difficult experiences. We had done this a number of times, and it became clear that,
some of the saddest moments of our lives and the process is really difficult right? It's not it's not a trivial process for the woman it's not a trivial process at all women have to take hormones so that it's not a trivial process. For the woman, it's not a trivial process at all. Women have to take hormones so that it's not just one egg that matures and can get harvested. And of course, it has to be surgically removed. So yes, it's a big deal. So these were difficult experiences. We had done this a number of times, and it became clear that,|||那是我们一生中最悲伤的时刻，而且这个过程真的很艰难，对吧？对女性来说，这绝不是一个微不足道的过程。女性必须服用激素，这样成熟并不止一颗卵子，才能被取出。当然，这还必须通过手术切除。所以是的，这是一件大事。这些都是痛苦的经历。我们已经做过好几次了，情况很明显——
well, it makes sense to do this one more time and if that doesn't work then that just seemed like we shouldn't do this anymore. That time the eggs just didn't there weren't as many they didn't seem as high a quality and they often in that case they'll say you know We'll just put them in anyway. There's nothing to lose here. But for whatever reason, they decided, no, these don't look good enough, and we don't want to even do the transfer of which at the time was devastatingly bad news. But a bad news story turns into one of the best stories of our lives.
well, it makes sense to do this one more time and if that doesn't work then that just seemed like we shouldn't do this anymore. That time the eggs just didn't there weren't as many they didn't seem as high a quality and they often in that case they'll say you know We'll just put them in anyway. There's nothing to lose here. But for whatever reason, they decided, no, these don't look good enough, and we don't want to even do the transfer of which at the time was devastatingly bad news. But a bad news story turns into one of the best stories of our lives.|||嗯，再试一次是有道理的，如果还是不行，那就说明我们不应该再做下去了。那一次，卵子数量没有那么多，质量似乎也不那么好，通常在这种情况下，他们会说：“你知道的，我们还是把它们植入体内吧。反正也没什么可失去的。”但出于某种原因，他们决定：“不，这些看起来不够好，我们甚至不想进行移植。”当时这绝对是个毁灭性的坏消息。但这个坏消息却变成我们一生中最美好的故事之一。
If they make the transfer, they give the woman a shot of progesterone to create the right uterine environment. But that means that even if it doesn't take, you're going to lose a menstrual cycle. And in a bizarre and delightful turn of fate, we conceived our own first delightful child, Alana, that month. So that if the doctor had said, okay, let's put it anyway, what's the harm?
If they make the transfer, they give the woman a shot of progesterone to create the right uterine environment. But that means that even if it doesn't take, you're going to lose a menstrual cycle. And in a bizarre and delightful turn of fate, we conceived our own first delightful child, Alana, that month. So that if the doctor had said, okay, let's put it anyway, what's the harm?|||如果他们进行移植，就会给女性注射黄体酮以营造合适的环境。但这意味著，即使没有着床，你也会失去一个月经周期。然而命运来了个奇异而美妙的转折，我们在那个月自然受孕，有了我们的第一个可爱的孩子——阿兰娜。所以，如果当时医生说：“好吧，不管怎样还是放进去吧，有什么害处呢？”
The possibility of her life would have been scratched. You know, every life, of course, is incalculably unlikely. It could have been the other sperm cell that inserted itself in there. And we think that all of us have to recognize just how unlikely it is that we ever existed. But this concretized that whole thing. It's another reason to celebrate our good fortune. What a wonderful story. I mean, and you have in some ways in your daughter almost a tangible representation of the thing that you should be grateful for, right? So some good things happen, but they don't walk around in front of us. But your daughter is right in front of you. And it's sort of almost a daily reminder of how fortunate you are.
The possibility of her life would have been scratched. You know, every life, of course, is incalculably unlikely. It could have been the other sperm cell that inserted itself in there. And we think that all of us have to recognize just how unlikely it is that we ever existed. But this concretized that whole thing. It's another reason to celebrate our good fortune. What a wonderful story. I mean, and you have in some ways in your daughter almost a tangible representation of the thing that you should be grateful for, right? So some good things happen, but they don't walk around in front of us. But your daughter is right in front of you. And it's sort of almost a daily reminder of how fortunate you are.|||她的生命可能就被抹去了。你知道，每一个生命当然都是概率极低、无法估量的奇迹。也可能是另一个精子钻了进去。我们认为，我们所有人都必须认识到我们能够存在是多么不可思议。但这把整件事具象化了。这是庆祝我们好运的又一个理由。多棒的故事啊。我的意思是，在某种程度上，你的女儿几乎成了你应当感恩的事物的有形化身，对吧？有些美好的事情发生了，但它们不会在我们的面前走来走去。但你的女儿就在你眼前。这几乎成了一种日常提醒，提醒你有多么幸运。
Yes, absolutely. That's beautifully said, Shankar. And I'm going to make sure my daughter listens to this. She can point out to me, see, Dad, I'm a walking embodiment of your good fortune. Ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha and found that even when we have a lot to be grateful for, gratitude doesn't come easily to most of us. Increasingly, Tom began asking himself a question, why is that? You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. A variety of psychological studies have found that gratitude is a powerful driver of human well-being.
Yes, absolutely. That's beautifully said, Shankar. And I'm going to make sure my daughter listens to this. She can point out to me, see, Dad, I'm a walking embodiment of your good fortune. Ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha and found that even when we have a lot to be grateful for, gratitude doesn't come easily to most of us. Increasingly, Tom began asking himself a question, why is that? You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. A variety of psychological studies have found that gratitude is a powerful driver of human well-being.|||是的，完全如此。这话讲得真好，尚卡尔。我一定得让我女儿听听这个。她可以指着我对我说：“看吧，爸爸，我就是你幸运的行走的化身。”哈哈哈哈……结果发现，即使我们有许多值得感恩的事，对大多数人来说，感恩也并非易事。汤姆开始越来越多地问自己一个问题：为什么会这样？你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔。各种心理学研究发现，感恩是人类幸福感的强大驱动力。
At Cornell University, psychologist Tom Gilevich says gratitude is an emotion that seems to unlock the best qualities in us. There's just been great work on the subject that shows just how generally beneficial it is and how beneficial in a variety of different ways. One way to summarize it is that we often use the phrase that, you know, we try to live up to our best self, we try to be our best self. And it turns out that it's easier to do that if you're feeling grateful. David Dosteno has done a bunch of great work on this subject where someone, you're in a bad situation and someone helps you out, you're just feeling so grateful to this person. And then you have an opportunity to take resources
At Cornell University, psychologist Tom Gilevich says gratitude is an emotion that seems to unlock the best qualities in us. There's just been great work on the subject that shows just how generally beneficial it is and how beneficial in a variety of different ways. One way to summarize it is that we often use the phrase that, you know, we try to live up to our best self, we try to be our best self. And it turns out that it's easier to do that if you're feeling grateful. David Dosteno has done a bunch of great work on this subject where someone, you're in a bad situation and someone helps you out, you're just feeling so grateful to this person. And then you have an opportunity to take resources|||在康奈尔大学，心理学家汤姆·吉洛维奇表示，感恩是一种似乎能激发我们最好品质的情绪。关于这个主题已经有很多出色的研究，表明它是多么普遍地有益，以及它在各种不同方面是如何有益的。总结的一种方式是，我们经常用这样一句话：你知道的，我们试图活出最好的自己，我们试图成为最好的自己。事实证明，如果你心怀感恩，就更容易做到这一点。大卫·多斯特诺在这个主题上做了一系列出色的研究：当你在困境中有人向你伸出援手时，你会对这个人充满感激。接着，如果你有机会获取资源——
for yourself or give it to other people. Third parties, you're more generous to other people. He's done the same kind of manipulations to make people feel grateful and then put them in a delay of gratification task where you can get a modest reward now or wait and get a greater reward. People find it easier to delay gratification
for yourself or give it to other people. Third parties, you're more generous to other people. He's done the same kind of manipulations to make people feel grateful and then put them in a delay of gratification task where you can get a modest reward now or wait and get a greater reward. People find it easier to delay gratification|||给自己还是分给其他人、第三方，你会对其他人更大方。他进行了类似的心理操纵，让人们产生感恩之情，然后让他们参与一个延迟满足的任务：现在你可以获得一个适度的回报，或者等待并获得更大的回报。人们发现更容易延迟满足——
when they're feeling grateful. I think a lot of the research can be summarized with this label of, you're a better person when you're grateful. Yeah. I mean, it's also been shown to improve your sleep and improve your health, perhaps even improve your relationships. Yes, exactly. There's research showing that
when they're feeling grateful. I think a lot of the research can be summarized with this label of, you're a better person when you're grateful. Yeah. I mean, it's also been shown to improve your sleep and improve your health, perhaps even improve your relationships. Yes, exactly. There's research showing that|||当他们心怀感恩时。我认为很多研究都可以用这样一个标签来概括：当你心怀感恩时，你会成为一个更好的人。是的。我的意思是，研究还表明它能改善你的睡眠，改善你的健康，甚至可能改善你的人际关系。是的，完全正确。有研究表明——
members of couples who are grateful for what their partners are doing and express it, that makes for healthier relationships. healthier relationships. To summarize then, we are happier, more generous, sleep better, and enjoy healthier relationships when we feel the emotion of gratitude. But Tom noticed that despite those benefits, even experts on human behavior found it hard to be thankful. I remember being a young assistant professor at Cornell, and we would invite speakers from around the country and around the world to talk about their research.
members of couples who are grateful for what their partners are doing and express it, that makes for healthier relationships. healthier relationships. To summarize then, we are happier, more generous, sleep better, and enjoy healthier relationships when we feel the emotion of gratitude. But Tom noticed that despite those benefits, even experts on human behavior found it hard to be thankful. I remember being a young assistant professor at Cornell, and we would invite speakers from around the country and around the world to talk about their research.|||伴侣双方如果对彼此的付出心存感激并表达出来，就会建立起更健康的关系。更健康的关系。那么总结一下，当我们感受到感恩之情时，我们会更快乐、更慷慨、睡眠更好，并享受更健康的人际关系。但汤姆注意到，尽管有这些好处，甚至连人类行为专家都发现很难做到心存感激。我记得在康奈尔大学做青年助理教授的时候，我们会邀请来自全国和世界各地的演讲者来谈论他们的研究。
So these are some of the leading lights in the field. And I remember a couple of them talking about, boy, you know, I've been mistreated in my life. Other people have gotten these breaks. I'm kind of on the outside. I'm an outsider and I'm thinking, well, you're a badest famous social psychologist can be. How hard is it really been?
So these are some of the leading lights in the field. And I remember a couple of them talking about, boy, you know, I've been mistreated in my life. Other people have gotten these breaks. I'm kind of on the outside. I'm an outsider and I'm thinking, well, you're a badest famous social psychologist can be. How hard is it really been?|||这些人都是该领域的领军人物。我记得其中几个人谈到：“天哪，你知道吗，我在生活中曾遭受虐待。其他人得到了这些机遇。我有点被排挤在外，我是个局外人。”我当时就在想，好吧，你可是大名鼎鼎的社会心理学家哎。生活究竟能有多难呢？
And I'm sure for them it was true. There were times that they faced various roadblocks on their career, but obviously they weren't that formidable, and they must have, in addition to their talents, had a break or two to get where they were, but they were focused on the, in their eyes, mistreatment. And I was just struck by that. That, wow. I'd like to be that influential and famous as they, and if that should ever happen, I sure hope that I don't have that same feeling
And I'm sure for them it was true. There were times that they faced various roadblocks on their career, but obviously they weren't that formidable, and they must have, in addition to their talents, had a break or two to get where they were, but they were focused on the, in their eyes, mistreatment. And I was just struck by that. That, wow. I'd like to be that influential and famous as they, and if that should ever happen, I sure hope that I don't have that same feeling|||我相信对他们来说这确实是真的。在他们的职业生涯中，确实曾遇到过各种绊脚石，但显然它们并非那么难以逾越，除了他们的天赋之外，他们一定也得到过一两次运气眷顾才能走到今天这一步，但他们却只专注于他们眼中所谓的虐待。我对此深感震撼。心想：哇，我也想像他们那样具有影响力和名望，如果真有那么一天，我真希望自己不会产生那种同样的怨恨情绪——
of resentment, of not having been appreciated. Now, you were a junior professor at the time, so I'm imagining that if you were so conspired, you wouldn't have actually voiced these thoughts, but did you actually ask any of them? Why it was that they were not more grateful? You are exactly right, chunker. I zipped it up, didn't say anything, but I filed it away as, wow, this is really interesting
of resentment, of not having been appreciated. Now, you were a junior professor at the time, so I'm imagining that if you were so conspired, you wouldn't have actually voiced these thoughts, but did you actually ask any of them? Why it was that they were not more grateful? You are exactly right, chunker. I zipped it up, didn't say anything, but I filed it away as, wow, this is really interesting|||一种未被赏识的怨恨。当时你还是一名初级教授，所以我猜如果你有这样的想法，大概也不会真的说出口，但你真的问过他们中的任何人吗？为什么他们不能更感恩一些？你说得完全对，尚卡尔。我闭紧了嘴巴，什么也没说，但我把这件事记了下来，心想：哇，这真的很有趣——
that you can be that successful and still feel resentment may be too strong, but something like resentment was brewing there, and I just thought that was really interesting. When he became the head of the psychology department at Cornell, colleagues would often bring complaints to Tom. Some complaints, of course, are legitimate, and as administrator you do whatever you can to try to write any wrongs, but there are times that someone will register a complaint that seems so powerful to them. And nonetheless to you, it can seem like pretty small
that you can be that successful and still feel resentment may be too strong, but something like resentment was brewing there, and I just thought that was really interesting. When he became the head of the psychology department at Cornell, colleagues would often bring complaints to Tom. Some complaints, of course, are legitimate, and as administrator you do whatever you can to try to right any wrongs, but there are times that someone will register a complaint that seems so powerful to them. And nonetheless to you, it can seem like pretty small|||一个人可以取得如此成功，却依然感到——怨恨可能有点太强烈了，但某种类似怨恨的东西在那里酝酿，我只是觉得这真的很有趣。当他成为康奈尔大学心理系主任时，同事们经常向汤姆抱怨。有些抱怨当然是合理的，作为行政人员，你会尽一切努力去纠正任何错误，但有时有人会提出他们认为非常强烈的抱怨。然而在你看来，这可能显得相当微不足道。
bore stuff. And you want to say, well, this is a very privileged job you have here. Go ahead and get a real job. Come back and then we'll talk about it. But again, I don't want to take away from the reality to the person level and the complaint. They aren't making them up. But what is it that makes this thing that can seem relatively small to the outsider so powerful and so unjust to the insider? We all see the same thing in our lives. We know people who
bore stuff. And you want to say, well, this is a very privileged job you have here. Go ahead and get a real job. Come back and then we'll talk about it. But again, I don't want to take away from the reality to the person level and the complaint. They aren't making them up. But what is it that makes this thing that can seem relatively small to the outsider so powerful and so unjust to the insider? We all see the same thing in our lives. We know people who|||你可能会想说：“好吧，你这份工作可是相当优越的。去吧，找个真正的工作，然后再回来跟我谈。”但话说回来，我并不想否定对当事人而言那种真实的感受和投诉。他们并不是在凭空捏造。但究竟是什么原因，让这个在局外人看来相对较小的事情，在局内人眼中却显得如此强大且如此不公？我们在生活中都见过类似的事情。我们认识这样的人——
constantly complain and are resentful of others. Invariably, these tend to be unhappy people. Since a feeling of appreciation feels so good when you're having it, it's kind of a paradox that we don't embrace it more. And so why is that? I decided to jump in on the subject of gratitude. What are the things that prevent us from being grateful or stated differently? What are the things that lead people to experience the opposite of gratitude. Your one opposite pull is you feel resentful. And another is feeling entitled. If you feel entitled, you're not being grateful.
constantly complain and are resentful of others. Invariably, these tend to be unhappy people. Since a feeling of appreciation feels so good when you're having it, it's kind of a paradox that we don't embrace it more. And so why is that? I decided to jump in on the subject of gratitude. What are the things that prevent us from being grateful or stated differently? What are the things that lead people to experience the opposite of gratitude. Your one opposite pull is you feel resentful. And another is feeling entitled. If you feel entitled, you're not being grateful.|||他们不断抱怨，对他人充满怨恨。无一例外，这些人往往都是不快乐的人。既然感恩的感觉在拥有时是如此美好，那么我们没有更多地去拥抱它，就成了一个悖论。这是为什么呢？我决定深入研究感恩这个主题。是什么阻碍了我们感恩？或者换句话说，是什么导致人们体验到与感恩截然相反的情绪？其中一个相反的拉力是你感到怨恨。另一个则是产生一种理所当然的特权感。如果你觉得一切都是理所当然的，你就不会感恩。
And if you're feeling resentful, you're not feeling grateful. And those are kind of toxic experiences. If you're reflect on times that you feel resentful, are you having fun at those moments? No, you're not. Think reflect on a time you feel resentful. Are you having fun at those moments? No, you're not. I think reflect on a time you're feeling grateful. Are you in a good mood? Yes, you are. So to try to approach gratitude from the back door seemed like a promising way to study
And if you're feeling resentful, you're not feeling grateful. And those are kind of toxic experiences. If you're reflect on times that you feel resentful, are you having fun at those moments? No, you're not. Think reflect on a time you feel resentful. Are you having fun at those moments? No, you're not. I think reflect on a time you're feeling grateful. Are you in a good mood? Yes, you are. So to try to approach gratitude from the back door seemed like a promising way to study|||如果你感到怨恨，你就不会感到感恩。这些都是有毒的体验。如果你反思自己感到怨恨的时刻，你在那些时刻过得开心吗？不，你并不开心。回想一下你感到怨恨的时候。你在那些时刻过得开心吗？不，你并不开心。我想，回想一下你心怀感恩的时候。你当时心情好吗？是的，你心情很好。所以，试图从“后门”来切入感恩，似乎是研究这种有趣情绪的一个很有前景的方法。
this interesting emotion. One reason Tom found we are less grateful than we should be is that we are largely ignorant about other people's troubles. First of all, other people's troubles are harder to notice than your own, and secondly, you are focused on the details of your own, so they loom a lot larger, all that anxiety that goes into figuring out what to do really burns it into the mind in a way that, oh, Shankar's going through some bad times right now, even if I'm very empathetic, it's harder to feel it with the same intensity that you're feeling.
this interesting emotion. One reason Tom found we are less grateful than we should be is that we are largely ignorant about other people's troubles. First of all, other people's troubles are harder to notice than your own, and secondly, you are focused on the details of your own, so they loom a lot larger, all that anxiety that goes into figuring out what to do really burns it into the mind in a way that, oh, Shankar's going through some bad times right now, even if I'm very empathetic, it's harder to feel it with the same intensity that you're feeling.|||汤姆发现，我们之所以没有应有的那样感恩，原因之一在于我们对别人的困境大都无知。首先，别人的麻烦比你自己的麻烦更难察觉；其次，你专注于自己麻烦的细节，所以它们显得要大得多。为了弄清楚该怎么做而产生的那些焦虑，真正深深地烙印在脑海里，以至于——哦，尚卡尔现在正经历一些糟糕的时光，即使我非常感同身受，也很难用你所感受到的那种强烈程度去体会它。
So, let's talk a little bit about some of the things that prevent us from experiencing gratitude. And let's start with something that we've explored at length on the show before, but is relevant here again, which is the idea that we adapt to the good things in our lives. Can you talk a moment about the Hedonic treadmill, Tom? Yeah, I mean, that's just a fundamental property of how the mind works. It's sensitive to changes in states rather than the states themselves. And when it comes to bad things, that adaptation or habituation is one of our greatest allies.
So, let's talk a little bit about some of the things that prevent us from experiencing gratitude. And let's start with something that we've explored at length on the show before, but is relevant here again, which is the idea that we adapt to the good things in our lives. Can you talk a moment about the Hedonic treadmill, Tom? Yeah, I mean, that's just a fundamental property of how the mind works. It's sensitive to changes in states rather than the states themselves. And when it comes to bad things, that adaptation or habituation is one of our greatest allies.|||所以，让我们来谈谈阻碍我们体验感恩的一些因素。首先从我们以前在节目中深入探讨过、但在这里依然相关的一个观点开始，那就是我们对生活中美好事物的适应。汤姆，你能谈谈“享乐适应”吗？是的，我的意思是，这只是大脑运作方式的一个基本属性。它对状态的变化敏感，而不是对状态本身敏感。说到坏事，这种适应或习惯是我们最好的盟友之一。
So we started this show talking about my motorcycle mishap. If I had experienced, let's say a spinal cord injury, we would call it not my motorcycle mishap. It's the motorcycle accident that would have changed my life. And like most people who have severe spinal cord injuries, it's hell at first. A lot of them say, I just don't want to do this anymore. Life isn't worth living. Fast forward six months a year, and the percentage of them who say that they're truly happy, really happy is very high. And their percentage of them say their life is
So we started this show talking about my motorcycle mishap. If I had experienced, let's say a spinal cord injury, we would call it not my motorcycle mishap. It's the motorcycle accident that would have changed my life. And like most people who have severe spinal cord injuries, it's hell at first. A lot of them say, I just don't want to do this anymore. Life isn't worth living. Fast forward six months a year, and the percentage of them who say that they're truly happy, really happy is very high. And their percentage of them say their life is|||我们在节目开始时谈到了我的摩托车事故。假设我遭遇了脊髓损伤，我们就不会称其为我的摩托车小意外了。那是会改变我人生的摩托车事故。就像大多数严重脊髓损伤患者一样，一开始简直是人间地狱。许多人说：“我再也不想这样了。活着毫无意义。”快进到六个月或一年后，他们中说自己真正快乐、非常快乐的比例非常高。而且他们当中说自己的生活——
close to their ideal. So something has gone on in that period of time and what is it? It's our ability to adapt. And this feature of the way the mind works is our greatest ally when it comes to bad things. When it comes to good things, it's a pretty potent enemy. You know, a good thing happens to you. You say, oh, thing happens to you. You say, oh, I'm going to appreciate this forever.
close to their ideal. So something has gone on in that period of time and what is it? It's our ability to adapt. And this feature of the way the mind works is our greatest ally when it comes to bad things. When it comes to good things, it's a pretty potent enemy. You know, a good thing happens to you. You say, oh, thing happens to you. You say, oh, I'm going to appreciate this forever.|||接近理想状态的人比例很高。所以在那个时间段内发生了一些变化，那是什么？是我们适应的能力。当面对坏事时，大脑运作方式的这一特征是我们最好的盟友。但当面对好事时，它却是一个相当强劲的敌人。你知道，当一件好事降临到你头上时。你会说，哦，好事降临到你头上时。你会说，哦，我会永远珍惜这个。
I'm never going to sweat the small stuff again. Fast forward a few months, and the small stuff is still driving you nuts. And you get mad at people in traffic, et cetera. You worry about all these tiny things that you swore you would never do. about all these tiny things that you swore you would never do. Can you talk about the notion of the asymmetry between what you call headwinds and tailwinds as being another source of our lack of gratitude? It's another enemy of gratitude. Yeah, I think this is easiest to understand for anyone who runs or cycles for exercise or
I'm never going to sweat the small stuff again. Fast forward a few months, and the small stuff is still driving you nuts. And you get mad at people in traffic, et cetera. You worry about all these tiny things that you swore you would never do. about all these tiny things that you swore you would never do. Can you talk about the notion of the asymmetry between what you call headwinds and tailwinds as being another source of our lack of gratitude? It's another enemy of gratitude.|||我再也不会为什么小事而烦恼了。快进几个月，那些小事依然把你逼疯。你会因为交通状况对别人发火，等等。你会为所有这些你曾发誓绝不会去计较的微小事情而担忧。关于所有这些你曾发誓绝不会去计较的微小事情。你能谈谈你所说的“逆风”与“顺风”之间的不对称概念，作为我们缺乏感恩的另一个来源吗？这是感恩的另一个敌人。
kayaks, there are times that you're having to go out into the wind and you're aware of it the entire time. It's literally in your face and you can't wait until you can turn around and enjoy the wind at your back. And when that happens, you do appreciate it for about a second. But then you lose sight of it because it just pushes you along. And what's true when it comes to those type of athletic events is true of life generally. The barriers in your way, the things that are arresting your progress, you've
Yeah, I think this is easiest to understand for anyone who runs or cycles for exercise or kayaks, there are times that you're having to go out into the wind and you're aware of it the entire time. It's literally in your face and you can't wait until you can turn around and enjoy the wind at your back. And when that happens, you do appreciate it for about a second. But then you lose sight of it because it just pushes you along. And what's true when it comes to those type of athletic events is true of life generally. The barriers in your way, the things that are arresting your progress, you've|||是的，我想对于任何跑步、骑自行车锻炼或玩皮划艇的人来说，这一点最容易理解：有时你必须迎风出行，你自始至终都能清晰地感受到风的存在。它真切地扑面而来，你迫不及待地想要转身去享受顺风。当那种情况发生时，你确实会感激它大约一秒钟。但随后你就忽略了它，因为它只是顺理成章地推着你向前走。在这些体育运动中适用的规律，在日常生活中也同样适用。阻挡在你面前的障碍，那些阻碍你前进的事物，你——
got to pay attention to them so that you can overcome them. Those things that are boosting you along, you can just enjoy them. You don't have to pay attention to them, just let them boost away. And in fact, that makes it hard to appreciate some of the things that we should be grateful for, some of the things that we should be grateful for, some of the things that we should be grateful for, or our tailwinds, and we lose sight of them. They are inherently less salient. Conversely, it's easy to feel resentful because you're very aware of the headwinds that you have to face, and if you're aware that some other people don't have them, it's very easy to get in touch with a feeling of resentment. Tom has run several studies showing how we easily recognize our obstacles, but fail to recognize
got to pay attention to them so that you can overcome them. Those things that are boosting you along, you can just enjoy them. You don't have to pay attention to them, just let them boost away. And in fact, that makes it hard to appreciate some of the things that we should be grateful for, some of the things that we should be grateful for, some of the things that we should be grateful for, or our tailwinds, and we lose sight of them. They are inherently less salient. Conversely, it's easy to feel resentful because you're very aware of the headwinds that you have to face, and if you're aware that some other people don't have them, it's very easy to get in touch with a feeling of resentment. Tom has run several studies showing how we easily recognize our obstacles, but fail to recognize|||必须关注它们，以便能够克服它们。那些在背后推着你前进的事物，你尽情享受就好了。你不需要去关注它们，让它们默默推着你走就行了。事实上，这使得我们很难去感激那些我们本该感恩的事物，那些我们本该感恩的事物，那些我们本该感恩的事物——也就是我们的“顺风”，而我们却忽视了它们。它们天生就没那么显眼。相反，人们很容易感到怨恨，因为你对必须面对的逆风有着深刻的体会；如果你意识到其他人并没有遇到这些逆风，你就非常容易产生怨恨情绪。汤姆进行过几项研究，表明我们如何轻易地识别出我们的障碍，却未能识别出——
our privileges. Take family dynamics. In a survey, Tom found that most children thought that parents were harshest on them and treated their siblings with greater leniency. In another example, Tom looked at sports fandom. One of the ways we looked at this was to look at the schedule of the National Football League. There are more teams than every team can play in a year. There are just too many teams. So you get your favorite team plays a subset of the teams in the NFL that may be different than the teams that you're rival of place. And there's a day every year when the schedule is announced. The Lions just had their schedule drop in. I'm not going to lie to you. It doesn't look good. Let's go.
our privileges. Take family dynamics. In a survey, Tom found that most children thought that parents were harshest on them and treated their siblings with greater leniency. In another example, Tom looked at sports fandom. One of the ways we looked at this was to look at the schedule of the National Football League. There are more teams than every team can play in a year. There are just too many teams. So you get your favorite team plays a subset of the teams in the NFL that may be different than the teams that you're rival of place. And there's a day every year when the schedule is announced. The Lions just had their schedule drop in. I'm not going to lie to you. It doesn't look good. Let's go.|||我们的特权。以家庭动态为例。汤姆在一次调查中发现，大多数孩子认为父母对他们最严厉，而对他们的兄弟姐妹更加宽容。在另一个例子中，汤姆研究了体育迷现象。我们研究这一点的方法之一是查看国家橄榄球联盟（NFL）的赛程表。参赛球队数量之多，以至于每支球队一年内无法与所有球队都交手。球队实在太多了。所以你支持的球队只会与NFL中一部分球队比赛，这可能与你死对头球队要打的比赛不同。每年都有公布赛程的日子。雄狮队刚刚公布了他们的赛程。我不会对你撒谎。这看起来不太妙。我们走吧。
The NFL schedule makers have put the 49ers in a big disadvantage. The NFL screwed the Buffalo Bills. The bills have the seventh hardest schedule in the NFL this year. And we just looked on Reddit to see how fans were reacting to it, and there were some times that people would say, oh good, we get to play that patsy in our stadium, can't wait for that. But those kinds of comments were very rare. It was much more of, oh my god, we've got to play the chiefs in arrowhead stadium yikes. That's going to be really tough. So what jumped off the page of the schedule were the headwinds, not the tailwinds. And I'm imagining in politics, it must be the same.
The NFL schedule makers have put the 49ers in a big disadvantage. The NFL screwed the Buffalo Bills. The bills have the seventh hardest schedule in the NFL this year. And we just looked on Reddit to see how fans were reacting to it, and there were some times that people would say, oh good, we get to play that patsy in our stadium, can't wait for that. But those kinds of comments were very rare. It was much more of, oh my god, we've got to play the chiefs in arrowhead stadium yikes. That's going to be really tough. So what jumped off the page of the schedule were the headwinds, not the tailwinds. And I'm imagining in politics, it must be the same.|||NFL的赛程制定者把49人队置于非常不利的地位。NFL坑了布法罗比尔队。比尔队今年的赛程是NFL中第七艰难的。我们刚刚在Reddit上查看了球迷们的反应，有时人们会说：“太好了，我们能在自己的球场上打那个软柿子了，迫不及待。”但这种评论非常少见。更多的是：“天哪，我们得去箭头球场打酋长队，哎呀。那可真是一场硬仗。”所以从赛程表上跃入眼帘的是逆风，而不是顺风。我猜在政治领域一定也是如此。
Each side feels the playing field is tilted toward the other. Yes, exactly. If you ask Democrats and Republicans, what about the elect... We've got this funny thing in the United States, the electoral college. Who does it favor? Each side thinks it favors the other side more. And interestingly, that's more true, the more that people follow politics.
Each side feels the playing field is tilted toward the other. Yes, exactly. If you ask Democrats and Republicans, what about the elect... We've got this funny thing in the United States, the electoral college. Who does it favor? Each side thinks it favors the other side more. And interestingly, that's more true, the more that people follow politics.|||每一方都觉得竞技场在向对方倾斜。是的，完全如此。如果你问民主党人和共和党人，关于选举……美国有个很有趣的东西，叫选举人团。它对谁有利？每一方都认为它对对方更有利。有趣的是，人们对政治关注得越多，这种感觉就越强烈。
The more you're in the political world, the more you're gonna get exposed to your side's headwinds, and therefore you're gonna believe this even more. Why do you think this is happening? I mean, at one level, we touched on one of these ideas, which is that our problems feel real to us and visceral to us in a way that other people's problems don't feel real and visceral to us, so we can appreciate that other people go through difficult times or have challenges
The more you're in the political world, the more you're gonna get exposed to your side's headwinds, and therefore you're gonna believe this even more. Why do you think this is happening? I mean, at one level, we touched on one of these ideas, which is that our problems feel real to us and visceral to us in a way that other people's problems don't feel real and visceral to us, so we can appreciate that other people go through difficult times or have challenges|||你越身处政治世界，就越会接触到自己一方的逆风，因此你会对此深信不疑。你认为为什么会这样？我的意思是，在某个层面上，我们触及了这样一个观点：我们自己的问题对我们来说是真实而刻骨铭心的，而别人的问题对我们来说则没有这种真实感和切肤之痛，所以我们可以理解别人经历艰难时期或面临挑战——
or have to climb uphill. But we're not actually doing the climbing. We're doing our climbing. Part of it is just simply, I think, a question of perspective. Who's shoes are you walking in? And depending on who shoes you're walking in, you're just going to feel what those shoes feel more intensely. Yeah, that's exactly right, Chunker. There's a way in which this is all part of the familiar story that we're all looking at the world through a small keyhole. And some things like our headw, are teed up for us and are easy to see and
or have to climb uphill. But we're not actually doing the climbing. We're doing our climbing. Part of it is just simply, I think, a question of perspective. Who's shoes are you walking in? And depending on who shoes you're walking in, you're just going to feel what those shoes feel more intensely. Yeah, that's exactly right, Chunker. There's a way in which this is all part of the familiar story that we're all looking at the world through a small keyhole. And some things like our headw, are teed up for us and are easy to see and|||或者必须逆境攀登。但我们并没有真正在替他们攀登。我们在攀登我们自己的山。部分原因其实很简单，我认为这是一个视角的问题。你穿着谁的鞋子走路？取决于你穿着谁的鞋子，你就会更强烈地感受到那双鞋所带来的触感。是的，完全正确，尚卡尔。在某种程度上，这完全是那个熟悉的故事的一部分：我们都在透过一个小钥匙孔看世界。有些事情，比如我们的逆风，已经为我们摆在眼前，很容易看到和——
acknowledge, whereas other things are in the shadows, outside the field of vision that that keyhole provides, and we tend to ignore them. It's a close cousin to the idea that our success is often psychologically disappear. We don't need to pay attention to them anymore, whereas our failure is they slurk. And that has important considerations and implications when it comes to the political world. So you have a political party that tries to meet certain challenges. You succeed at some and fail at others. The public they're gonna keep hammering you for the things that you failed at. So you know, as an early part of the New Deal, I think it was largely Democrats that pushed to electrify the
acknowledge, whereas other things are in the shadows, outside the field of vision that that keyhole provides, and we tend to ignore them. It's a close cousin to the idea that our success is often psychologically disappear. We don't need to pay attention to them anymore, whereas our failure is they slurk. And that has important considerations and implications when it comes to the political world. So you have a political party that tries to meet certain challenges. You succeed at some and fail at others. The public they're gonna keep hammering you for the things that you failed at. So you know, as an early part of the New Deal, I think it was largely Democrats that pushed to electrify the|||承认，而其他事情则隐匿在阴影中，在那个钥匙孔所提供的视野范围之外，我们往往会忽视它们。这与另一个观点有着紧密的亲缘关系：我们的成功在心理上往往会消失。我们不再需要去关注它们，而我们的失败却在潜伏盘旋。当涉及政治世界时，这具有重要的考量和深远的影响。所以，一个政党试图应对某些挑战。你在某些方面成功了，在另一些方面失败了。公众会因为你失败的事情而不断对你穷追猛打。所以你知道，作为新政的早期部分，我认为主要是民主党人推动了——
countryside in the United States. Democrats are not getting continued credit for rural electrification or the creation of social security, which basically ended the kind of old age poverty that existed then, just doesn't exist anymore, and they benefited from that electrically for a while, but it's just part of the landscape and they don't get credit for it now, whereas other parts of the safety net that don't work so well, the problems with it get stuck to them. And that works for both parties.
countryside in the United States. Democrats are not getting continued credit for rural electrification or the creation of social security, which basically ended the kind of old age poverty that existed then, just doesn't exist anymore, and they benefited from that electrically for a while, but it's just part of the landscape and they don't get credit for it now, whereas other parts of the safety net that don't work so well, the problems with it get stuck to them. And that works for both parties.|||美国的乡村电气化。民主党人并没有因为农村电气化或社会保障的建立而继续获得赞誉，社会保障基本上终结了当时存在的那种老年贫困，现在这种贫困已经不复存在了。他们曾在电气化方面从中受益一段时间，但这只是现状的一部分，他们现在不会因此获得赞誉，而社会保障网中那些运作得不太好的部分，其存在的问题却一直纠缠着他们。这对两党来说都是如此。
Successes disappear, failures tend to hang around psychologically. You've also done some work looking at how many of us see shared burdens as being unusually burdensome for us. Can you talk about this worktop? Yeah, so this is work I did with a former student Carmen San, who came to Cornell from working in the financial world. And we were struck by just how often people complain about any changes to tax laws and the regulatory environment. And consistent with the headwinds tailwinds idea, we thought that, look, this thing that is
Successes disappear, failures tend to hang around psychologically. You've also done some work looking at how many of us see shared burdens as being unusually burdensome for us. Can you talk about this worktop? Yeah, so this is work I did with a former student Carmen San, who came to Cornell from working in the financial world. And we were struck by just how often people complain about any changes to tax laws and the regulatory environment. And consistent with the headwinds tailwinds idea, we thought that, look, this thing that is|||成功会消失，失败在心理上往往会挥之不去。你还做了一些研究，探讨我们当中有多少人认为共同的负担对我们而言异常沉重。你能谈谈这项研究吗？好的，这是我和前学生卡门·萨恩一起做的研究，她从金融界来到康奈尔大学。我们感到震惊的是，人们是如此频繁地抱怨税收法律和监管环境的任何变化。与“顺风逆风”的观点相一致，我们认为，看吧，这个——
designed at least to affect everybody the same, we're much more aware of how it's affecting us and we might have some distant feel that it's, oh, it's affecting you too, but it just can't compare to the richness of how it has hurt my life. So if the taxes go up, I think it has hurt me more than it's hurt you. If a tax burden goes down, I think I've benefited from it more than it's benefited you. And this piggybacks on research that was done a number of years earlier by two different teams of researchers, one of former student of mine, Justin Krueger and Paul Winshittle, and at the same time a paper by Don Moore, now at Berkeley, that showed that any sort
designed at least to affect everybody the same, we're much more aware of how it's affecting us and we might have some distant feel that it's, oh, it's affecting you too, but it just can't compare to the richness of how it has hurt my life. So if the taxes go up, I think it has hurt me more than it's hurt you. If a tax burden goes down, I think I've benefited from it more than it's benefited you. And this piggybacks on research that was done a number of years earlier by two different teams of researchers, one of former student of mine, Justin Krueger and Paul Winshittle, and at the same time a paper by Don Moore, now at Berkeley, that showed that any sort|||至少旨在对每个人产生相同影响的事物，我们对它如何影响我们有着更深刻的体会，我们或许对它会有一种遥远的感知，觉得“哦，它也在影响你”，但这根本无法与它如何伤害我生活的丰富细节相提并论。所以如果税收上涨，我认为它对我的伤害大于对你的伤害。如果税收负担减轻，我认为我从中获得的益处大于你从中获得的益处。这延续了多年前两支不同的研究团队所做的研究，其中一支是我以前的学生贾斯汀·克鲁格和保罗·温希特尔，同时还有现任职于伯克利大学的唐·穆尔的一篇论文，该论文表明，任何类型的——
of shared burden seems more burdensome to us, and you think it has a bigger impact on you than on other people. Gratitude, like many emotions, involves social comparison. Very often, we are not asking what we have or don't have. We're asking what we have or don't have relative to what others have and don't have. Tom found this in space when he did a study on elite athletes at the Olympics. The Olympic Games has this kind of unique structure where there are three medals given out. There's the gold medal winner,
of shared burden seems more burdensome to us, and you think it has a bigger impact on you than on other people. Gratitude, like many emotions, involves social comparison. Very often, we are not asking what we have or don't have. We're asking what we have or don't have relative to what others have and don't have. Tom found this in space when he did a study on elite athletes at the Olympics. The Olympic Games has this kind of unique structure where there are three medals given out. There's the gold medal winner,|||共同的负担对我们来说似乎更具负担感，你会认为它对你产生的影响比对其他人产生的影响更大。感恩和许多情绪一样，涉及社会比较。很多时候，我们不是在问我们拥有什么或没有拥有什么。我们是在问，相对于别人拥有和没有的东西，我们拥有什么或没有拥有什么。汤姆在对奥运会精英运动员进行研究时，在体育领域发现了这一点。奥运会有这样一种独特的结构：颁发三枚奖牌。有金牌得主，
and then the second place finisher gets a silver, and third place gets bronze. And then after that, no more medals. Everybody wants the gold. The gold gets you on the witty box. You become famous if you win that. And you might think that, okay, the gold medal winner is going to be happiest.
and then the second place finisher gets a silver, and third place gets bronze. And then after that, no more medals. Everybody wants the gold. The gold gets you on the witty box. You become famous if you win that. And you might think that, okay, the gold medal winner is going to be happiest.|||然后第二名获得银牌，第三名获得铜牌。在那之后，就没有更多的奖牌了。每个人都想要金牌。金牌能让你登上领奖台。如果你赢得金牌，你就会成名。你可能会想，好吧，金牌得主一定是最开心的。
The silver medal winner will be next happiest because they finish second, and the bronze medal winner will be the third happiest. But if you look at it from the perspective of what are the thoughts likely to be going through the heads of these athletes, the silver medalist is going to be thinking, I almost won the covered gold. If I just got now a little faster, if I'd made a stronger push at just at the end, I'd be up there on the gold medal stand rather than that person. The bronze medalist could be, and many of them certainly are saying the same things. Oh, if I just pushed out a little earlier, I'd have the gold medal. But that's harder for them.
The silver medal winner will be next happiest because they finish second, and the bronze medal winner will be the third happiest. But if you look at it from the perspective of what are the thoughts likely to be going through the heads of these athletes, the silver medalist is going to be thinking, I almost won the covered gold. If I just got now a little faster, if I'd made a stronger push at just at the end, I'd be up there on the gold medal stand rather than that person. The bronze medalist could be, and many of them certainly are saying the same things. Oh, if I just pushed out a little earlier, I'd have the gold medal. But that's harder for them.|||银牌得主第二开心，因为他们获得了第二名，而铜牌得主第三开心。但如果你从这些运动员脑海中可能会闪过的想法这个角度来看，银牌得主会想：“我差一点就赢得了梦寐以求的金牌。如果我当时再快一点点，如果在最后冲刺时再加把劲，站在金牌领奖台上的人就会是我，而不是那个人。”铜牌得主也可能会——而且他们中的许多人肯定也在这样说：“哦，如果我早一点发力，金牌就是我的了。”但这对他们来说更难。
They've got to make up two different slots to get to the gold medal. And much closer is not being on the medal stand at all. And so we looked at the Olympic Games in 1992 from Barcelona, Spain. And a lot of footage of athletes on the medal stands, lots of footage of athletes right at the moment. They just touched the edge of the pool, look up and see that they finished in second or third place. And then we had people rate those facial expressions.
They've got to make up two different slots to get to the gold medal. And much closer is not being on the medal stand at all. And so we looked at the Olympic Games in 1992 from Barcelona, Spain. And a lot of footage of athletes on the medal stands, lots of footage of athletes right at the moment. They just touched the edge of the pool, look up and see that they finished in second or third place. And then we had people rate those facial expressions.|||他们必须跨越两个名次才能拿到金牌。而离他们更近的现实是根本无法登上领奖台。于是我们研究了1992年西班牙巴塞罗那奥运会。我们收集了大量运动员站在领奖台上的镜头，以及运动员刚刚触到泳池边、抬头看到自己获得第二或第三名那一瞬间的大量镜头。然后我们找人对这些面部表情进行评分。
And it turns out that in both venues on the medal stand or in the immediate aftermath of the end of the performance, civil-medalists just look less happy than the bronze medalists. President Theodore Roosevelt wrote, comparison is the thief of joy. I can't feel thankful for what I have if I think you have more than I do. It is woven into our psychological experience again. It's often not the thing itself, but how the thing compares to something else.
And it turns out that in both venues on the medal stand or in the immediate aftermath of the end of the performance, civil-medalists just look less happy than the bronze medalists. President Theodore Roosevelt wrote, comparison is the thief of joy. I can't feel thankful for what I have if I think you have more than I do. It is woven into our psychological experience again. It's often not the thing itself, but how the thing compares to something else.|||结果表明，无论是在领奖台上的颁奖仪式上，还是在比赛刚结束后的那一刻，银牌得主看起来就是没有铜牌得主开心。西奥多·罗斯福总统写道：“攀比是快乐的小偷。”如果我认为你拥有的比我多，我就无法对拥有的东西心存感激。这再次交织在我们的心理体验中。通常重要的不是事物本身，而是该事物与其它事物的对比。
What was it like earlier or what is it like compared to something that someone else does? And this of course is the familiar keeping up with the Jones' idea that you get a new car. If your neighbor gets a new car on the very same day that you did and it's a better car than yours that can rain on your parade and make it harder to enjoy that. So these are some of the enemies of gratitude. We adapt to the good things in our life and quickly forget our blessings. We focus intensely on the headwinds that slow us down,
What was it like earlier or what is it like compared to something that someone else does? And this of course is the familiar keeping up with the Jones' idea that you get a new car. If your neighbor gets a new car on the very same day that you did and it's a better car than yours that can rain on your parade and make it harder to enjoy that. So these are some of the enemies of gratitude. We adapt to the good things in our life and quickly forget our blessings. We focus intensely on the headwinds that slow us down,|||它以前是什么样子的？或者与别人所做的事情相比，它是什么样子的？这当然就是我们熟悉的“攀比心理”（不落人后），比如你买了一辆新车。如果你的邻居在你买新车的同一天也买了一辆新车，而且比你的车更好，这就会大煞风景，让你很难去享受它。这些就是感恩的一些敌人。我们适应了生活中的美好事物，并很快忘记了我们的福气；我们全神贯注于那些让我们放慢脚步的逆风，
but take the tailwinds that propel us forward for granted. We mistakenly believe the burdens shared by many are burdens that we bear alone. What all of these have in common is that we have a self-centered view of life. Even worse, we don't realize that we are seeing the world through a narrow keyhole of self-interest. In order to feel gratitude, we need to take a wider, more expansive view. For a few lucky people, this expansive world view comes easily. This allows them to bathe in the good feelings of gratitude and enjoy its many psychological benefits. The psychologist Jonathan Height calls this winning the cortical lottery. Tom says that while this might be true, it may be useful to think about the
but take the tailwinds that propel us forward for granted. We mistakenly believe the burdens shared by many are burdens that we bear alone. What all of these have in common is that we have a self-centered view of life. Even worse, we don't realize that we are seeing the world through a narrow keyhole of self-interest. In order to feel gratitude, we need to take a wider, more expansive view. For a few lucky people, this expansive world view comes easily. This allows them to bathe in the good feelings of gratitude and enjoy its many psychological benefits. The psychologist Jonathan Height calls this winning the cortical lottery. Tom says that while this might be true, it may be useful to think about the|||却把那些推动我们前进的顺风视为理所当然；我们错误地认为，许多人共同承担的负担是我们独自一人在承受。所有这些共同的特点是，我们对生活持有一种以自我为中心的观点。更糟糕的是，我们没有意识到我们是通过自私的狭隘钥匙孔在看世界。为了感受到感恩，我们需要采取更宽广、更开阔的视野。对少数幸运的人来说，这种开阔的世界观轻而易举就能拥有。这使他们能够沉浸在感恩的美好感受中，并享受其带来的诸多心理益处。心理学家乔纳森·海特称之为“赢得了大脑皮层彩票”。汤姆说，虽然这可能是真的，但思考以下内容可能会有所帮助：
ability to take on an expansive worldview as a skill, something that can be learned with practice. One of my academic advisors, Lee Ross, said that there's a lot of very good work on happiness. It's very informative. And it's guided by the idea that some people have more of a trait of happiness. And it wasn't that he was saying that that was wrong, but he was saying that if we think of it not so much as a trait
将广阔的世界观作为一种技能来掌握，这是可以通过练习学到的。我的学术导师之一李·罗斯（Lee Ross）说过，有很多关于幸福的极佳研究，它们信息量很大。其核心思想是，有些人天生就具有更多的幸福特质。他并不是说这种观点是错的，而是说如果我们不把它看作是一种特质
but a talent, we might gain some additional purchase on this. This goes back to the idea whether you've won the cortical lottery or not. That makes you more talented at thinking about the world in a way that's pleasing to you and you come out being happier. The barriers to gratitude in our lives are plentiful, summarized from within us, others we learn from those around us. Collectively, they can keep us from noticing what is good in our lives and reaping the benefits of gratitude. When we come back, breaking through these barriers, you'll listen to Hidden Brain, I'm
而是一种天赋，我们可能会对此有更深的理解。这就回到了你是否赢得了皮层彩票的问题。这让你更有天赋以一种令自己愉悦的方式看待世界，从而让你变得更幸福。我们生活中通往感恩的障碍有很多，它们源于我们自身，源于我们周围的人。总的来说，这些障碍阻碍我们去注意生活中的美好，并收获感恩带来的好处。稍后我们将探讨如何突破这些障碍，你收听的是《隐藏的大脑》，我是
Shankar Vedantam. Tom Gilevich is a psychologist at Cornell University. He finds that while gratitude has a host of positive influences on our lives, our minds regularly trick us into not being grateful. Tom wanted to fight these enemies of gratitude, and one answer came to him as he thought about the example of humanitarians who do good works in the world. We clearly adapt very quickly to good things happening to us, but do we similarly adapt to the good things that we do for others?
香卡·维丹塔姆（Shankar Vedantan）。汤姆·吉洛维奇（Tom Gilevich）是康奈尔大学的心理学家。他发现，尽管感恩对我们的生活有着诸多积极影响，但我们的大脑经常欺骗我们，让我们不去感恩。汤姆想要与这些感恩的敌人作斗争，当他想到那些在世界上做好事的人道主义者时，他找到了一个答案。我们显然很快就会适应发生在我们身上的好事，但我们是否也会同样适应我们为别人所做的好事呢？
Tom thought about someone like Mother Teresa. Imagine that she saves ex people today. Is it likely to be the case that next week, if she only saves that many people, she's gonna say, oh, this isn't enough, I need to save more and more. Is she on sort of a benevolent, hedonic treadmill? And that just doesn't seem right. If you're doing good for others, you're in a sort of a different world, a different
汤姆想到了像特蕾莎修女这样的人。假设她今天拯救了X个人。如果下周她只拯救了同样数量的人，她会不会说：“哦，这还不够，我需要拯救更多更多的人”？她是否处于一种仁慈的享乐适应水轮上？这似乎不太对。如果你在为别人做好事，你其实是处于一个不同的世界，一个不同的
psychological world where adaptation is going to be less of a problem. And I mentioned that example in my introductory social psychology course a number of years ago, and I probably sloppily said, and so go out and purchase experiences that adaptation isn't as powerful for those. As many of us as I want to do when we're speaking off the cuff, Tom made a mental leap. His hypothesis was that the happiness we get from doing good deeds would be resistant to the hedonic treadmill. He extrapolated from that with a new idea. That all experiences might produce more enduring happiness than the pleasure
心理世界，在这个世界里，适应问题将不再那么严重。多年前，我在我的社会心理学入门课上提到过这个例子，我当时可能有点草率地说：“所以去购买体验吧，对于体验来说，适应的效果没那么强烈。”正如我们很多人在即兴发言时想做的那样，汤姆实现了一次思维上的飞跃。他的假设是，做好事带来的快乐将能够抵御享乐适应。他由此推断出一个新想法：所有的体验可能都比我们从物质中获得的快乐
we get from stuff. After Tom finished his lecture, his teaching assistant approached him with a question. After Tom finished his lecture, his teaching assistant approached him with a question. My TA at the time, Leaf Bend-Bovon, now a very successful professor of Social Psychology at the University of Colorado, came up to me and said, oh, that was really interesting. Can you tell me the paper that shows that? And I kind of went, oh, I guess I got over my skis there. There was no research on that. So he and I set about examining, do you adapt less for the experiences you have? Is it the case that, you know, if you go to a gratifying musical concert, is it the next one that's that good? Is that going to
产生更持久的快乐。汤姆讲完课后，他的助教走过来向他提问。汤姆讲完课后，他的助教走过来向他提问。我当时的助教利夫·本-博翁（Leaf Bend-Bovon），现在是科罗拉多大学社会心理学非常成功的教授，他走过来对我说：“哦，这太有趣了。你能告诉我证明这一点的论文吗？”我当时有点不知所措，心想：“哦，我好像有点班门弄斧了。”当时并没有关于这方面的研究。于是我和他开始着手研究：对于你所经历的体验，你适应得会比较少吗？比如说，如果你去听了一场令人愉快的音乐会，接下来的那场音乐会也会这么好吗？那场音乐会还会像上一场
be as gratifying? Well, yeah, probably. Does it have to be better the next time? We're not always seeking greater and greater concert experiences. And so we put it to the test by asking people, think about the best experiential thing you purchased in the last, let's say, five years, or other people think about the best material thing you've purchased, let's say in the last five years, and then we ask them, how much do you enjoy it now, how much do you consider that money, well spent, etc. And what you find is that people say they get more enduring satisfaction from their experiential purchases than from their material purchases. And why do you think this is happening?
那样令人愉快吗？嗯，是的，大概会吧。下一次一定要更好吗？我们并不总是在追求越来越宏大的音乐会体验。因此，我们通过一项测试来验证这一点：我们让人们回想一下在过去（比如说）五年里购买的最佳体验，或者让其他人回想一下在过去五年里购买的最佳物质物品，然后我们询问他们现在有多享受它，他们觉得这笔钱花得有多值，等等。结果你就会发现，人们表示，他们的体验式消费比物质消费获得了更持久的满意度。你认为这是为什么呢？
Well, that's the interesting part. Why is that? And it turns out that there's at least three things that are big drivers of why we get more enduring satisfaction from our experiences. One of them is that experiences connect us to other people more. So, you know, imagine that you and I just discovered that, oh, we're wearing the same tennis shoes. We feel a little closer to each other because we share this material thing. That's true. But it's nowhere near as true as, oh, you and I just saw the same concert when you share those kinds of
嗯，这就是有趣的部分。为什么会这样？事实证明，至少有三件事是让我们从体验中获得更持久满意度的主要驱动力。其中之一就是体验能让我们更多地与其他人建立联系。所以，你知道，假设你和我刚刚发现，“哦，我们穿着同一款网球鞋。”因为我们分享了这个物质东西，我们会觉得彼此更亲近一点。确实如此。但这远远比不上“哦，你和我刚刚看了同一场音乐会”那样的体验。当你与某人分享这种
experiences with someone you feel much more connected to them and you are enriched in that way. So that's one thing. Experiences also, they build up who we are. We are in some sense the some total of our experiences. You know, we identify with our stuff, but however much we care, they are separate from you. And you're not building the same personal capital as you are when you're experiencing things. You become a different person through the different things that you've done. And therefore, if we're building up that self, we're building up something very substantial. And then finally, the third thing is the very thing that you mentioned earlier, which
体验时，你会觉得与他们的联系更加紧密，并且你也在那种方式上得到了丰富。所以这是一点。体验还能塑造我们是谁。从某种意义上说，我们就是我们所有经历的总和。你知道，我们认同我们的物品，但无论我们多么在乎它们，它们终究是与你分离的。当你体验事物时，你并没有积累同样多的个人资本。通过你所做过的种种不同事情，你变成了一个不同的人。因此，如果我们正在塑造那个自我，我们就是在构建非常实质性的东西。最后，第三点就是你刚才提到的那件事，即
is the comparisons that we make, the kind of in-videous comparisons. Oh my God, I just got this new pair of sneakers and your sneakers are better. I got this new car, your car is better. That kind of keeping up with the Joneses. It applies to experiences. It can be a little deflating to see that someone else got to spend two weeks on vacation. You only got to spend one. But we've shown in study after study that it's just much less pronounced.
我们所做的比较，那种嫉妒性的比较。天哪，我刚买了一双新运动鞋，而你的运动鞋比我的好。我买了辆新车，你的车比我的好。这种与邻居攀比的心理。它也适用于体验。看到别人去度假了两周，而你只去了一周，可能会让人觉得有点泄气。但我们在多项研究中表明，这种比较的程度要轻得多。
One of the things that you recommend when it comes to the headwinds, tailwinds, asymmetry is a version of asking ourselves the question, what am I missing? What information do I need to seek out? Can you talk about this as one of the ways to defend against this enemy of gratitude is to actually go out and solicit the information that helps us understand that in fact other people are walking uphill as much as we are. Other people are paying their fair share of taxes and it's a burden on them as much as it's a burden on us.
当你面对顺境与逆境的不对称性时，你推荐的方法之一就是问自己这样一个问题：我错过了什么？我需要寻找什么信息？你能谈谈这是抵御感恩之敌的方法之一吗？即真正走出去，主动寻找那些能帮我们了解事实的信息：其实别人和我们一样在艰难前行。别人也承担了他们应付的税收负担，这对他们来说和对我们一样是一种负担。
That just sort of seeking out the information itself can be an antidote to this enemy of gratitude. Yeah, if it's an informational problem, then the problem can be solved by seeking out different kinds of information. That turns out that's a key to good judgment and decision-making generally. It can be hard to do. Decision-making researchers often talk about this as consider the opposite. The mind automatically thinks of all the reasons for the thing that you're entertaining. Things that run against it, it's just the mind isn't prepared to, as energetically look for it. The mind is already going to look at the kinds of, it's already going to seize upon the kinds of things
主动寻找信息本身就可以成为这种感恩之敌的解药。是的，如果这是一个信息问题，那么这个问题就可以通过寻找不同类型的信息来解决。事实证明，这是做出良好判断和决策的关键。这做起来可能很难。决策研究人员经常把这称为“考虑相反的情况”。大脑会自动思考你所考虑的事情的所有理由。而对于相反的事情，大脑并没有准备好去积极地寻找。大脑总是会去寻找那些
going to look at the kinds of, it's already going to seize upon the kinds of things that can make you feel envious, entitled, and resentful, and finding those relatively invisible tailwinds that takes more effort. And so that is a habit that has to be cultivated. We've talked a lot in this conversation about noticing things to be grateful for, but it's also you and others have found it's really important to try and find ways to express these things that we're grateful for. Can you talk a little bit about the work that's been done that talks about the importance of expressions of gratitude, like open and explicit expressions of gratitude as an engine
会让你感到嫉妒、觉得自己应得一切以及愤愤不平的事情，而要发现那些相对隐形的顺境则需要更多的努力。因此，这是一种必须培养的习惯。我们在这次对话中讨论了很多关于注意值得感恩的事物，但你和其他人也发现，尝试寻找表达我们感激之情的方法也非常重要。你能谈谈这方面所做的工作吗？这些工作谈到了表达感激之情的重要性，比如公开和明确地表达感激之情，将其作为
for feeling thanks? Yeah, a couple of people you've had on your show before, two former students, Nick Epley and Amit Kumar, have done this great work on that, that people often are reluctant to reach out and express gratitude to other people, even though they deeply feel it. And it seems like one of the barriers there is you feel like,
感受谢意的引擎。是的，你节目之前请过的几位嘉宾——两位前学生尼克·埃普利（Nick Epley）和阿米特·库马尔（Amit Kumar）——在这方面做过很棒的研究。他们发现人们经常不愿意主动去向其他人表达感激之情，尽管他们内心深处对此有着深刻的感受。其中的障碍之一似乎在于你会觉得：
I'm going to say this just right, otherwise, you know, who knows how it will be received. And I'm not so sure I'm very good at writing, expressing my gratitude exactly right. And what they've shown is the gratitude recipient doesn't really care about the quality of it. They just care about the fact that you took the time to do it. You can botch your gratitude letter and still, oh, this person feels that way. It's enormously gratifying for them. And this highlights a saying that's generally attributed to Maya Angelo that I think is one of the wisest statements about human
我一定要把这话表达得恰到好处，否则，谁知道会被怎么接收呢。而且我不太确定自己是否擅长准确地用文字表达谢意。但他们的研究表明，接受感谢的人其实并不在乎质量如何。他们只在乎你花时间去做了这件事。即使你把感谢信写得一团糟，哦，这个人还是能感受到这种心意。这会让他们感到巨大的满足。这突显了一句通常归功于玛雅·安杰洛（Maya Angelou）的名言，我认为这是关于人类
behavior that's anyone's ever said, which is people will not remember what you did, they won't remember what you said, but they'll remember how you made them feel. So whether you can write a kind of gratitude letter that Ian McHughan would write, that doesn't matter. Just the fact that you took the time will register. It will make the other person feel good and that's what's important.
行为最明智的陈述之一，任何人都没有说过比这更好的，那就是：人们不会记得你做了什么，他们不会记得你说了什么，但他们会记得你给他们的感觉。所以，无论你能写出一封像伊恩·麦克尤恩（Ian McEwan）那样文采斐然的感谢信，这并不重要。仅仅是你花了时间这件事本身就会留下印记。它会让对方感觉良好，而这才是最重要的。
And it will make you feel good as well. Hmm. You know, one of the things that we've been doing on Hidden Brain for a few years is to list an unsung hero at the end of each of our episodes. And a couple of years ago, we started a spin-off show called My Unsung Hero, where people recount a moment in their lives when someone came to their assistance in a moment of need. And these are short stories, you know, two minutes long, three minutes long, four minutes long. So they're not very long stories, but they capture a snippet of something that happened in someone's life many many years ago.
而且它也会让你感觉良好。嗯。你知道，我们在《隐藏的大脑》中已经做了好几年的事情之一，就是在我们每一集的末尾列出一位无名英雄。几年前，我们开办了一个衍生节目叫《我的无名英雄》，人们在节目中讲述他们生命中的某个时刻，当时有人在他们需要帮助的时候伸出了援手。这些都是很短的故事，你知道，两分钟长、三分钟长、四分钟长。所以它们不是很长的故事，但它们捕捉到了许多年前发生在某人生活中的某个片段。
What's been striking, I think, is that one, people remember these moments, decades and decades into the future. They can be very small moments. And in fact, the person who has done them the kind deed probably has not even been aware that they did a kind deed or they've long forgotten it. But the person remembers it far into the future. And the second thing that's been very interesting time is that when I listen to stories about person A, thanking person B, and I don't know person A and I don't know person B, but there's something about listening to that act of gratitude, that expression of gratitude,
令人瞩目的地方在于，我认为，第一，人们会记住这些时刻，几十年甚至几代人之后依然记得。它们可能非常短暂。事实上，那个对他们施以善意的人可能甚至没有意识到自己做了件好事，或者早就把它忘得精光了。但当事人却在很久以后依然记得。第二件非常有趣的事情是，当我听到关于A感谢B的故事时，我不认识A，也不认识B，但不知为什么，听着那个感恩的举动、那种感激的表达，
that makes me feel good, and makes me feel like maybe I want to do something that helps someone else as well. Can you talk about the psychology that's happening here? There's something very interesting because I don't know either of these people but seeing gratitude expressed in the world somehow makes us feel like being better people. Yeah, that's really interesting.
会让我感觉良好，让我觉得或许我也想做点什么来帮助别人。你能谈谈这其中涉及的心理学机制吗？这非常有趣，因为我不认识这两个人中的任何一个，但看到世界上有人表达感激之情，不知怎的，就会让我们觉得自己想要成为更好的人。是的，这真的很有趣。
And it relates to some work we're doing now, Shae Davidi and I about what are those tailwinds that we do appreciate? They tend to be ignored. They're less salient than headwinds, but sometimes we do note them and what are the kinds that are noted. And overwhelmingly, the boosts you get from other people. If it's that kind of headwind, you're just much more likely to notice it. And so, you know, at the Academy Awards, people express thanks. All the thanks are directed at other people. It's not things that, oh, I grew up in a rich family
这与我们现在正在做的一些研究有关，我和谢伊·达维迪（Shae Davidi）正在研究：我们究竟会感激哪些顺境？它们往往被忽视。它们比逆境不那么显眼，但有时我们确实会注意到它们，那么被注意到的到底是哪种顺境呢？绝大多数情况下，是你从其他人那里得到的助力。如果是那种顺境，你更有可能会注意到它。所以，你知道，在奥斯卡颁奖典礼上，人们会表达感谢。所有的感谢都指向其他人。并不是说，“哦，我生长在一个富裕的家庭，
and so I was able to take singing lessons at an early age. People don't say that. Or I've just born with the kind of genes that I'm incredibly handsome. And that's why I got these roles. No one says that, of course, but they do talk about other people. So some kinds of tailwinds are more salient than others and those are more social.
所以我很小就能上声乐课。”人们不会这么说。或者“我天生就长着一副难以置信的英俊面孔，这就是我能得到这些角色的原因。”当然没有人会这么说，但他们确实会谈论其他人。因此，某些顺境比其他顺境更显眼，而那些顺境往往更具社交属性。
We are moved by all of those things that bring us together. So when you see person A expressing gratitude to person B, even if you don't know A or B, it's just very moving. Just the other day, we discovered this note that our daughter, the very daughter I talked about before, wrote to my wife when she was six years old. I find it very moving, but she wrote,
我们被所有那些将我们凝聚在一起的事物所打动。所以当你看到A向B表达感激之情时，即使你不认识A或B，这也非常感人。就在前几天，我们发现了一张便条，那是我们的女儿——也就是我刚才提到的那个女儿——在她六岁时写给我妻子的。我觉得这非常感人，她在上面写道：
you've been in my family for six years, and in all that time you've been loving me in such a kind way. Thank you for being this nice to me. This picture, she drew a little picture of irises, is yours to cherish when you are old and frail and your garden does not bloom. Keep it for the time.
你在我们家里已经六年了，在所有这些时间里，你一直用如此善良的方式爱着我。谢谢你对我这么好。这幅画——她画了一小幅鸢尾花——是留给你的，当你年老体衰、你的花园不再盛开时，你可以好好珍藏它。留着它，为了那个时刻。
Keep it, get this. Keep it for the time when you're going to have the longest snap of your life. I think she's already anticipating my wife shedding this mortal coil. I think that's what she's referring to. But anyway, I saw that and it just found it very charming. referring to, but anyway, I saw that and it just found it very charming. Yeah. And what do you think is happening in you when you're hearing that story? I mean, it's obviously these are people whom you know, these are not strangers, but what do you think is happy? Why is it moving to Utah to hear this? It's just, you know, it's good to see another person's loving heart. And so even if it's strangers and you see one person reaching out to another, it's a one-best self expressing itself to another and that's just really heartening.
留着它，听着这个。留着它，为了你将要经历生命中最长的一次长眠的时候。我想她已经在预料我妻子即将寿终正寝了。我想这就是她所指的。不管怎样，我看到那个，只觉得它非常迷人。是指这个，不管怎样，我看到这个，只觉得它非常迷人。是的。当你听到那个故事时，你觉得自己内心发生了什么？我的意思是，显然这些都是你认识的人，这些不是陌生人，但你觉得发生了什么？为什么听到这个会让你觉得感动？这只是，你知道，看到另一个充满爱的心灵是美好的。所以，即使是陌生人，当你看到一个人向另一个人伸出援手时，那是最好的自我向另一个自我展露，这真的非常鼓舞人心。
Tom Gilevich is a psychologist at Cornell University. He's the author of the wisest one in the room, how you can benefit from social psychology's most powerful insights. Tom, thank you for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Oh, absolutely. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Bridget McCarthy, Annie Murphy Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Quarelle, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, Andrew Chadwick, and Nick Woodbury. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor.
汤姆·吉洛维奇是康奈尔大学的心理学家。他是《房间里最聪明的人：你如何从社会心理学最强大的见解中获益》（The Wisest One in the Room）一书的作者。汤姆，谢谢你今天做客《隐藏的大脑》。不客气，绝对的。《隐藏的大脑》由隐藏大脑传媒公司（Hidden Brain Media）制作。我们的音频制作团队包括布里奇特·麦卡锡（Bridget McCarthy）、安妮·墨菲·保罗（Annie Murphy Paul）、克里斯滕·王（Kristen Wong）、劳拉·夸雷尔（Laura Quarelle）、瑞安·卡茨（Ryan Katz）、奥特姆·巴恩斯（Autumn Barnes）、安德鲁·查德威克（Andrew Chadwick）和尼克·伍德伯里（Nick Woodbury）。塔拉·博伊尔（Tara Boyle）是我们的执行制片人。我是《隐藏的大脑》的执行主编。
As Tom and I were talking about unsung heroes during our interview, Tom asked me if he could mention one of his own. So here is today's unsung hero during our interview. Tom asked me if he could mention one of his own. So here is today's unsung hero from Tom Gilevich. Well, since I'm here in the recording studio at Cornell University, the person who makes it all happen, Bert, he's just amazing. Everything goes super smoothly. I owe him a lot as so many of us do.
正当我和汤姆在采访中谈论无名英雄时，汤姆问我是否可以顺便提一下他自己心中的无名英雄。所以在今天的采访中，以下是汤姆提到的无名英雄。汤姆问我是否可以顺便提一下他自己心中的无名英雄。所以在今天的采访中，以下是来自汤姆·吉洛维奇的无名英雄。嗯，既然我是在康奈尔大学的录音室里，那个让这一切成为现实的人，伯特（Bert），他简直太棒了。一切都进展得超级顺利。我欠他很多，我们中的很多人都欠他很多。
He makes me sound better than I am. You're sounding just like you are. You sound great. Well, since Birds on the Line let me thank Bird as well. And I'll just note that to build anything actually requires so many people who are on Sung Heroes. And Bird, thank you for helping make this interview so successful. Well, thank you. It's been a total pleasure. I'm Shankar Vedantan. See you soon. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
他让我听起来比实际上更好。你听起来就是你本来的样子。你听起来棒极了。嗯，既然伯特在线，请允许我也感谢伯特。我只想指出，要真正建立任何东西，确实需要许许多多无名英雄。伯特，谢谢你帮助这次采访取得了如此巨大的成功。谢谢你。这绝对是一种享受。我是香卡·韦丹塔姆。再见。目前本集还没有评论。点击转录文本中的任意句子即可留下评论。